here's the bureaucracy that's going to
be produced every college or university
shall collect from its students faculty
staff and other persons
whatever that means and provide to the
minister such data and other information
related to the following as may be
requested by the minister
the number of times support services
complaints resolutions and accommodation
relating to racism are requested made
and obtained by students enrolled at or
faculty or staff of the college or
university and information about those
supports any anti-racism initiatives and
programs established by the college
university to promote awareness of the
supports and services
the number of incidents and complaints
of racism reported by students faculty
and staff and information about how such
incidents incidents and complaints
including
how the incidents and complaints were
addressed or resolved the implementation
and effectiveness of the policy so that
means every and that's not just for
colleges and universities if i have read
this correctly
it's throughout the education system as
a whole so that means the establishment
of a bureaucracy that
is
devoted to doing nothing but gathering
such data and reporting it and so all
you have to do is think for about 15
seconds to imagine what that's going to
mean because
systems tilt themselves to
produce what is being measured
so but again it's
where are they going with this i mean
this is again it's it's it is from the
authoritarian regimes
you check on thought
you check on the number of complaint and
by the way if you start to invite
complaints on a truly hot subject
it can get very personal very quickly to
people in their various jobs teaching
broadcasting
business anywhere else if you set up an
investigative structure and a reporting
structure and a tabulation structure if
i want to do damage to you and if i pick
the right side of this particular
context i'm going to move you out
we we cannot we cannot allow the
bureaucratization
of the search into people's attitudes
and souls
to become a legislative possibility i
you know i i get legislated on the
system
yeah this is let me give you one other
thing this is a proof of what i just
said this is a very high high standard
proof this is great britain itself i'm
just going to redid the headlines again
it's a story it's print it's real
they're their race oversight his name
was tony sewell
and he wrote a report he was appointed
by boris johnson this is not you know
some freelancer
uh and uh he founded britain and here's
again like
trudeau would systemically raise he
found by the way he's black which
shouldn't matter but these days we have
to say it
he found that britain was not
institutionally racist
and then and blast northland hammer
university cowards for withdrawing his
university honorary degree he was given
a degree in 2019
but they withdrew it after a study that
was commissioned by him objective in
nature
not proving certainly asserting
that britain was not institutionally
racist and they said this was
done to him because he was the subject
of political controversy well let me
give you a translation of that
the accepted idea among the world class
is that we're all now a bunch of racist
homophobes islamophobes transfer name
the folk iraqi vote
that has to be accepted as absolute law
however
if a person from even one of those
groups this is again the racist star of
great britain appointed by
tony i'm sorry by
boris
and he reports after doing an objective
survey and he himself a black person no
we're not universally racist
and then all the correct thought stars
and the university types and the
politicians and most of the newspapers
dump him he's thrown out the same thing
happened to roland fryer in harvard
university who did a statistical study
of of shootings by police officers and
found that more whites proportionately
were shot than blacks he had won the
world's top economics prize as a young
black man
and yet he got nailed on a sexual
assault harassment idea but the real
provocation behind it was because he
reported some good news
on the so-called racial front good news
is now bad news good news is racist in
itself there's two people high stature
high qualifications both black
both
ostracized because they spoke a clear
truth against these doctrines so where
are we jordans my question i i don't
know anymore maybe we'll maybe we'll
close by just reviewing this last
section so this is in schools in general
and
uh one of the subsection alterations
here is not that the minister may
establish that's re that's replaced with
the wording the minister shall establish
so this now becomes a requirement
that
policies and guidelines
have to be put in place
with respect to promoting racial equity
in schools which must include policies
and guidelines respecting
training in this racial equity doctrine
for all teachers and other staff
resources to support people's teachers
and staff who have been targeted by
racism
strategies to support people's teachers
and staff who witness
incidents of racism resources to support
them who have engaged in racist
behaviors procedures this is really a
terrible one procedures
that allow pupils teachers and staff to
report incidents of racism safely and in
a way that minimizes the possibility of
reprisal so there goes facing your
accuser and there goes the presumption
of innocence and that necessitates the
establishment of quasi-judicial boards
of inquisition
the use of disciplinary measures within
the framework in response to racism
etc etc
etc the details that you've outlined
here and again you've done a closer read
but these are you know
it sounds rhetorical but it isn't
these are horrifying
we don't let other people
judge other people and we don't bring in
a crowd of self-dedicated unidimensional
predetermined minds
on some particular cause then to become
judiciary investigator punisher
publisher
of other people
and we're also building the whole idea
of an anti-racism curriculum that is
this deep and this obsessional
is that you are exceeding to the to the
thought
that the thousands and thousands of
ontario teachers
are morally deficit
they're morally we that we have been
running a system here and until we get
these
these these new angels
of racial purity and start teaching them
all about bias and oppression and
everything else that the bunch running
in our schools are either uneducated or
bigots
but again i saw here's the thing that
more than i got to keep saying it
once you make obsessional and pervasive
and saturated the concept the critical
racial theory and make that the soul of
the educational effort
you have displaced the educational
effort
you are choosing young people you are
cheating their parents you are lying to
them
i would much rather i would would like
to see just one month
that eight or nine ontario school boards
put out something
not racist not about sex not about
transgender not about environmentalism
but about a damn subject in their
schools and how it's betting better when
was the last time
that the educational authorities of this
province started firing out bulletin
saying boy are we are we teaching better
than we've ever taught before
our students are alive with the hunger
for knowledge and they are ecstatic when
they find new adventures in thought
their minds are growing their characters
are stronger they love their country
how's that is another one to throw in
there
and where instead of this is this alien
perverse
angry
useless doctrine becoming the central
the cardinal impulse and dynamic
of a modern educational system
it is terrible
well rex i think that's probably a good
note on which to
end this rather pessimistic discussion
yeah and the liberals
the small liberal types canadians in
general parents in ontario and in canada
take the time to actually read through
this bill and think about it and then to
try to ask themselves how in the world
we got to this place
that's the big question how do we get
here how do we get out of it
jordan thank you very much for your time